before we say goodbye we like to play a  quick roundup truth or dare  and we have nicole danyaquo hi nicole hi  how are you i'm good i have a dare for  you today okay  all right i dare you both to a bubble  gum blowing contest whoever blows the  biggest bubble wins  okay here we go  okay uh oh wow hard  hard  okay  oh well i'm working her out  okay are you close  the editor is  i'm  like  well okay come on  they've always said i have the strongest  jaws in the business so give me another  oh i bet they do  [Laughter]  okay  you got one  i mean i have met new york strip steaks  that like break down easier than that  ryan  i can blow great bubbles at home  it's a tie we'll just call it a time  [Applause]  i'm better than this  [Music]